so keeping in mind how much salt you
should be taking in if you're on a
low-sodium diet now I'm just gonna write
that here low-sodium diet I was thinking
you know of all the foods that I
typically like to consume and and where
that fits into the amount that I'm
allowed in a given day so if I'm on a
low-sodium diet the amount we said was
about 1,500 milligrams of sodium per day
and this is sodium not salt remember and
if if I go through a few foods out
that'd be fun to kind of figure out how
much sodium is in these foods so let's
start out with something I had not too
long ago so I said I just was recently
on a road trip and I stopped off on the
side of the road and I picked up one of
my favorite little snacks which was a
large carton of fries so I had some
fries and they were delicious so these
large fries and I actually love to eat
fries with ketchup so I had five ketchup
packets and another so that was one food
item and another food item I've had many
many times especially when I'm kind of
in a big rush and I don't have time to
go out and get a proper lunch I'll I'll
sit down and grab a cup of noodles so
I'll grab a cup of noodles and you've
had these they basically are kind of
dehydrated noodles that are in here and
and if you're like me you love them but
this is a cup of noodle so this was
another item I thought would be good to
look at and the next item of the last
item is actually similar to the company
rolls it's actually not a cup of noodles
but the kind that you might take when
you're sick so whenever I'm sick one of
the things I always reach for is a pot
of water and I like to boil up the water
and cook a block of noodles inside of it
and put the flavoring packet there and
this is again these are the dehydrated
noodle
and I like to eat those and so you know
my dehydrated noodles in a pot of water
and I'll call that a block of noodles
and I usually eat one whole block at a
time with the flavoring so I've got a
few things here blocking noodles cup of
noodles and also my large fries with
ketchup and I know my limit is 1500
milligrams in a day so how far along do
these things get me so one by one let me
just tell you the answer the large fries
with packets of ketchup five packets is
about 900 milligrams of sodium the cup
of noodles is about 1200 milligrams of
sodium and you can see I'm going up up
up and so my block of noodles is
actually 1600 milligrams of sodium so
actually this one puts me over the
amount that I'm allowed in a whole day
and that's actually usually what I would
have just for lunch and so it's an
immense amount of sodium tons of sodium
and so it got me thinking you know how
in the world I'm not actually on a
low-sodium diet but if I was how in the
world would I be able to do it and so I
was browsing the internet and I came
across a website which I'm gonna share
with you and it's basically from the
Mayo Clinic and actually I don't want to
say that this is the only website there
tons of great websites out there but
this one website actually got me
thinking and so what I thought is why
don't I figure out what kind of food I
could actually get if I was on a
low-sodium diet what would make sense
and so I picked out a few things from
their website that I thought would be
tasty they have one thing that's a
roasted salmon this is my salmon and if
I eat the roasted salmon with olive oil
and chives the amount of sodium is 60
milligrams not bad right and let's say I
want to eat that with some potatoes so I
got some roasted potatoes over here
which I love roasted potatoes as soon as
my dad and these roasted potatoes get me
seven milligrams of sodium so this is my
roasted potatoes seven mmm
sodium yeah she dropped the e there
sorry so um you know I potatoes great
Salmons great but I like my vegetables
and so what if I get some asparagus in
there so some roasted asparagus and
there's a recipe for some mushrooms with
the roasted asparagus this meal is
looking better and better and so if I
get some asparagus with the mushrooms
that's an additional 11 milligrams of
sodium so it's actually pretty
reasonable and in fact since I'm doing
so well I actually was tempted to go to
their dessert menu and I actually
grabbed one of the recipes for apple pie
and apple pie is an American favorite
it's certainly one of my favorites and I
love to make apple pie and that gets me
about 16 milligrams of sodium so if I'm
totaling all of this up I have I'll do
it in the corner here I've got um let's
say 60 plus seven plus 11 plus 16 and
that total comes to be 71 78 88
94 milligrams of sodium
and so 94 milligrams of sodium is well
within my limit of 1500 milligrams of
sodium per day so this is one place you
can go to get some good food
recommendations as I said there are many
many others as well